the vast majority of attacks on trump
are complete bs notably the idea well
starting with the idea that he colluded
with the russians turns out there was a
total fed democrat hoax and we now know
that for a fact but two
the idea that donald trump tried to
stage a coup d'etat
on january 6 the worst day ever in
american history and if we were this
close to being governed by the
dictatorship of the horn hat guy but we
made it through so that that's obviously
completely absurd and and that never
happened
but did you catch the insurrection that
did happen
no probably not because you you wouldn't
have heard about it and it wasn't talked
about on the front pages of the new york
times and the washington post and blared
endlessly on all of the stupid left-wing
news networks but there was at if
january 6 was an insurrection there was
an insurrection
in the wisconsin state house
[Applause]
did you hear that if you weren't
watching if you're just listening to
this show right now i'll describe the
scene for you it wasn't horn hat guys
painted in red white and blue popping
cores wearing maga hats it was it was a
bunch of
left wingers wearing pink t-shirts
planned parenthood t-shirts they were
chanting shut it down
we don't care all throughout the
wisconsin state house
if january 6 was an insurrection
certainly this was an insurrection too
they're explicitly
trying to interfere with government
business they are saying shut it down
shut down what shut down the legislature
shut down the government shut down the
law making process the pros the law
making process in wisconsin's sacred
temple to our democracy no you don't
hear any of that because the libs don't
care about it because in this case the
insurrectionists are on their side
and they don't really care about our
democracy or anything like that when the
libs say democracy they just mean
liberalism progressivism leftism the
sort of stuff that they are after just
another reminder
not to take anything about january 6th
seriously at all it's a complete
political operation it the way that it's
talked about is a hoax is is exaggerated
to the point of of really just being a
fabrication and people are still
attacking trump
if you're still attacking trump even in
that great temple to our sacred
democracy eric swalwell the man who was
almost president
one of the first people out of the 2020
democrat presidential primary who later
was found out to be sleeping with a
chinese spy who never stops stepping on
rakes of his own making eric swalwell
tells this harrowing tale from the
capitol
today i gave a tour in the capital and
was stopped by a father with his young
boy the father yelled at me hey swalwell
then told his son that swole well he's
trouble he doesn't back trump i kept
walking and felt sad for the boy he's
being raised in a cult family
in a cult family because a republican
made fun of swalwell and said we're
backing the other guy we're not backing
the democrats we're back that's a cult
according to them the people who believe
that men can secretly be women and who
are chopping off the genitals of
children that they they're accusing
other people of being in a cult because
we backed the republican who wanted to
cut our taxes and and let us be a little
bit freer
that's what they say and it's important
this kind of language is important they
it's not a mere political disagreement
here they are delegitimizing any
opposition if you oppose them in any way
you contradict them in any way it's not
just that you're kind of wrong and we're
going to fight you at the ballot box
it's that you are a dangerous
insurrectionist terrorist cult member
and you will be dealt with accordingly
hi i've been meaning to send in a
message for a couple weeks and i'm
finally getting around to it this is a
little out of date now but during your
debate with a girl over abortion one
thing i noticed you didn't point out
which i've seen very few people point
out is the false equivalence of her
analogy whether it's the violin analogy
or a car or she framed it the analogy
posits that allowing the natural flow of
events leads to death and taking direct
action by contravening nature leads to
life where in reality inaction leads to
a living baby and taking action directly
leads to a dead baby the false
equivalence goes directly toward the
pro-abortion side's deliberate reframing
of pregnancy is an unnatural occurrence
like a
parasitic infection that needs to be
stopped and i think a lot of people on
that side would be against that if they
understood where the arguments were
coming from similar to how they would be
for abolishing roe if they knew the
actual impact that will god willing have
it's a dishonest framing and i wish
you'd pointed that out during the debate
would your thoughts be there
my thoughts are you're exactly right
it's a very good point to make there are
lots of problems with the stupid violin
analogy and all sorts of arguments for
abortion but i have very little to add
there i think you're you're totally
right
one of the problems debating abortion is
there it's so wrong it's so wrong for so
very many reasons that one could be
there all day and you kind of have to
pick and choose but i agree that's a
very good point i'm glad you brought it
up well well put i couldn't have said it
any better myself i'm so glad you like
that clip now hold up stop stop in the
name of love ring that bell ding dong
like it smash it click it whatever you
got to do get the notifications for the
michael knowles show we're approaching a
million subscribers which is really
extremely fun i want my i want my big
gold button from youtube before they
shut me down permanently go do it we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]